you know I'm really truly happy that
susan sarandon speaking out for me and
you know it's we've got to get this out
to people we've got to stop this from
happening we've gotta stop it - not
happening to me but other people and
it's just really crazy but it's not to
this point there was an article done
recently by a guy named Kenneth Jones
and energy says the Prophet did we put
the welcome 7/16 in schedule but the
actual killers still alive the case will
be one more example of a system that
defines both weapons to be fair and just
or even simply to make sense
exactly my case is a perfect example of
that you know Helen cuisine renin start
looking into my case and she can see for
herself this is truly a case of an
innocent man that's going to be executed
and I couldn't ask for a better person
to stand up and speak out for me and I'm
glad that she has and I hope that you'll
continue to do so for some reason dr.
Thielen is not looking at it the way
there's a man about to be executed if
you want everything in their power to
stop that from happening
if you believe that your system is fair
and just why aren't you speaking out to
put a stop to this it just doesn't make
any sense but I'm purely blessed to have
so many people that are speaking out in
support and I think she's ready for
coming on board and speaking out for me
and I hope that people will continue to
themselves you have to make a difference
Richard you and I have spoken about your
case many times before but viewers who
are watching this for the first time
will listen to a man who's on death row
saying he's innocent and think we'll
hang on doesn't everyone say that
doesn't everyone plead innocence when
they are facing what you were facing so
why should why should people believe you
that you are innocent of this
well for one I am I do understand what
you're saying I think that's why I've
always when I've done interviews working
all our bones invited them to go to
Richard Glossip calm and they can see
all the stuff in themselves and they can
read it for themselves to come to the
decision by themselves but all you have
to do is look into my page and you can
see everybody who has which is thousands
and thousands of people who have these
claims can see that it's truly the
change of innocence
I got tourney's and it's come on board
pro bono investigators that have come on
for mom because they've all looked into
my case and they think is justice I mean
we gotta stop telling people period in
this country but when you start killing
the innocent and you think that that's
okay that's just crazy
the only thing I can say to truly answer
your questions to ask people to please
just go to reach me drop cloth calm look
for yourself but everything that's out
there and you will see from yourself
that what I'm saying is the truth
when I am innocent and they are going to
execute an innocent man it's a lot to
take clothes you've said before that you
made mistakes in the aftermath of the
van trees murder that you were told by
Justin's need that he had committed this
murder and you didn't believe him and
you didn't tell anyone else you didn't
talk to the police at the time you know
except that that was a mistake and made
you look like a guilty man I've been
told I had asked somebody and this
person even told to take this mess so I
mean I just problem somebody else's with
rice and it
ended up being bad advice and it made me
look bad but I did not have anything to
do with this man's back I didn't
participate in that and now it's just
the sad thing about it this people are
going differently to situations and and
that's what I did I just reacted and
into a situation a service and nobody
often watch it when I decided to but I
wanted to go to all the place where I'm
sold
I should have went there right there and
told them and I listened to somebody
else instead and it couldn't me in a bad
light so I did make mistakes by
listening to other people and it just
ended up making me look like a bad
person when I was just a mistake
back in January you came within 24 hours
of an execution date you're now six
weeks from a new execution date how do
you think it's going to go what's going
to happen in the next six weeks do you
hope that's going to make September the
16th a date when you avoid execution who
spoke out against the death and you know
we're executing some people in this
country and your sign to abolish
definitely in the shop and it should be
because it's not okay so I gotta have
sound system all right but I still have
to have to even our justice system it
it's going to come out right I mean I
hope that the Supreme Court will hear in
this case finally and what it is and
that's the fact that and it's a man's
got to be executed I mean there's been
investigated reformers off the United
States and even into the country sort of
energy on that have looked into my case
deeply like the cornballer if you want
and it just shocks them to see that I'm
on death row it just can't figure out
how they can be possible how can a guy
who never committed the crime in his
life with everything right bills babies
taxes now I'm fighting for my life how
do you go from that to that I mean it
doesn't make any sense
Richard Glossip thanks very much indeed
for talking to us that's Richard also
speaking to us from death low death row
at the Oklahoma State Penitentiary in
McAlester Oklahoma back to you Donnie